[Music]
hi i'm candify
today
i'll be showing you how to make japanese
candier
i first came to us 1996 because disney
world invited me to work for them since
then
i've lived in florida for this my candy
show i've got 17 years until i moved to
new york in 2017.
i'm based in new york where i travel all
over the country for events birthday
party
wedding
baby shower burmese fires and sometimes
as a do amusement park the most
important tools that i use are japanese
scissors are clogged power and food
colors candy is very
delicate the most difficult process of
candy making to adjust the hardness or
the candy
every day the temperature humidity
change and day after the consistency of
the candy
very subtle they made a huge difference
in candy making as all of the candy
artists intuition to determine when the
candy is ready to be pressed on the
stick
when you get it at the perfect timing
you can form the candy into anything
why did i decide to become a candy
artist well
i tried all the
jobs i wanted
and i finally discovered my destiny it
was the number 13 and this is the last
one
how do i know that
because i can never get tired of my
business
it is a 300 years old traditional
japanese candier i've been embracing the
tradition but always creating something
new did you know that there are only
five female candy artists in japan now
i'm the first woman in the history
i have a unique style of candy making i
still have a japanese traditional airman
but it's also an american pop art to
make you chuckle all of my candy have a
personality
that's candy 5 style
i can make anything and everything with
candy but most popular for girls and
unicorns for boys it's a dragon others
often want pets like a dog or cat if you
show me picture of your pet
or even your family
friend
celebrity or anyone i can make them with
candy
i love challenge if you are watching
this video one thing i wanna tell you
don't hesitate to challenge yourself
don't give up then you'll find your plus
oh yes
[Music]
you